2 millions 700 mille c'est le nombre de
doses astrazeneca reçu dans l'hexagone
et qui n'ont pas été employés dans le
cadre de la vaccination des français
pris d'assaut font en début d'année face
aux difficultés d'approvisionnement des
états européens le produit qui a depuis
été délaissées en cause les cas de
thrombose atypique signalé après
injection l' agence nationale du
médicament en recense une trentaine en
france un vaccin qui a en plus à
démontrer des résultats décevants face
au coc u19 à la fin de l'année 218 1012
auront périmé depuis le début de la
campagne de vaccination issus du stock
d'état ce sont soit des doses
prépositionné chez les grossistes
répartiteurs afin d'accélérer les
livraisons en ville au printemps soit
des doses qui avait été réservé à des
dons bilatéraux mais qui n'ont
finalement pas été livrés faute de
récipiendaire malgré ce désamour
apparent les livraisons se poursuivent
après un différend entre la commission
européenne et le laboratoire en raison
de retards de livraisons
un accord a été conclu entre les deux
parties et d'ici la fin du premier
trimestre 2011 22 astrazeneca s'est
engagée à livrer un total supplémentaire
de 200 millions de doses le laboratoire
anglo-suédois doit fournir en plus des
quelques 100 millions de doses livrées
jusqu'à la fin du deuxième trimestre
2000 21 135 millions de doses d'ici fin
2021 60 millions de doses à la fin du
troisième trimestre et 75 millions de
doses à la fin du quatrième trimestre et
les doses restantes 65 millions d'ici la
fin du mois de mars 2022 ce qui portera
le nombre total de doses livrées à 300
millions de doses soit ce qui avait été
convenu dans le contrat d'achat anticipé
conclu le 27 août 2020 au prorata de la
population ce sont 17 millions 800 mille
nouvelles doses qui devraient donc pas
revenir à la france en début d'année
2022 mais que va-t-on faire d'un vaccin
interdition moins de 55 ans inéligible à
la troisième dose responsable de
plusieurs cas de thrombose et dont les
résultats contre le coc u19 son décevant
en l'absence de tout usage sur le
territoire national à ces doses
devraient être redirigé vers kovacs
dispositif piloté par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui doit permettre
à une centaine de pays en développement
de recevoir des doses de vaccin
gratuitement alors si personne ne veut
de l'astra zeneca dans l'hexagone c'est
l'envers ce pourfendeur qui est pour sa
part en rupture de stock vous avez pris
rendez vous pour une dose de rappel de
vaccination qu'ovide 19 à 20 heures au
centre de vaccination
conformément aux nouvelles directives
nationales transmise à ce jour par
l'autorité régionale de santé ce rappel
se fera en moderna vaccin lui aussi arn
messagers pour toutes les personnes de
plus de 30 ans c'est le message type
qu'ont reçu de très nombreuses personnes
de région parisienne ayant réservé un
rendez vous pour une dose de rappel
vaccinal des changements
d'approvisionnement et deux vaccins qui
ne sont pas problématiques
à en croire le professeur alain fischer
président du conseil d'orientation de la
stratégie vaccinale les deux vaccins
fonctionnant avec la technologie de la
rn messager pour les médecins ils sont
donc en théorie
interchangeables sans risque la dose de
rappel entraîne un niveau de protection
très élevé en termes d'anticorps
neutralisants aussi bien avec pfizer que
moderna le professeur alain fischer
précise toutefois son propos la petite
nuance c'est sur la tolérance ce qui a
conduit à n'utiliser moderna qu'après
l'âge de 30 ans parce que parmi les
effets indésirables de façon extrêmement
rare pour la deuxième injection chez les
hommes on observe un peu plus de cas de
myocardite voilà qui ne va pas arranger
la défiance de certains français à
l'égard de modern à une récente étude
danoise vient de confirmer un lien entre
ce vaccin et de rares cas de problèmes
cardiaques cette même étude publiée dans
le british medical journal elle fait
aussi état de risques cardiaques liés au
vaccin de pfizer mais uniquement chez
les femmes la vaccination avec moderna
est associée à un risque plus élevé de
myocardite ou de péricardite en premier
lieu les 12 39 ans la myocardite c'est
la péricardite sont des inflammations du
coeur
selon les auteurs de cette étude les
risques apparaissent trois à quatre fois
plus élevé chez les vaccinés moderna
dans le mois qui suit la vaccination que
chez les vaccinés preiser biotech il
insiste sur le fait que ces problèmes
cardiaques restera ray compris chez les
moins de 40 ans vaccinés par moderna
puisque environ
0,005 % d'entre eux sont concernés
plusieurs autorités sanitaires dont
celles de la france et du danemark ont
déjà suspendu l'usagé du vaccin moderna
pour les plus jeunes l'islande quand
elle il ya me sens pour tous les adultes
à l'heure où le gouvernement appelle les
français à se faire vacciner face aux
variants omicron la gestion des stocks
de vaccins mériterait une vigilance
toute aussi importante